you can see the video that we just
showed on the live look and on on its
Channel 239 DirecTV in the NBC Sports
Network you can go to the app the French
kid did a great job in editing that down
or the guys went out there with their
Odyssey putters now your results may
vary with that Odyssey putter is a great
putter you would never know that by how
the Dan that's treated it as Paulie said
thank God we had the odyssey putters in
the way you guys putted I don't know
what you would have done if you didn't
have the Odyssey putter now Paulie ended
up winning and then McLovin came in
second fritz he came in third if we
could show the scorecard on the back
monitor there and if you guys could look
at that I believe that is is that
paulie's scorecard is that what that is
Paulie you that's everyone's score card
together McLovin handled this final
scoring okay so everybody there and if
you'll look and see oh no did everybody
sign the scorecard which makes it
official let's check everybody did
everybody sign the scorecard looks like
someone's missing dad it looks like
Paulie did not sign the scorecard
McLovin signed it yeah that's the thing
that you're missing in the mom at all
let's bring in rich Lerner from the Golf
Channel they esteemed host and of course
a rules official in his part-time and
rich could you help us here with the
backdrop of not signing your scorecard
not just any rules official ban but a
miniature golf rules official because my
father
rest in peace owned a miniature golf
course driving range and fully lighted
part three in Allentown Pennsylvania so
bottom line okay
it's about as egregious an error as
there is in our sport failure to sign a
scorecard you look at the USGA rules it
is actually rule six - six failure to
sign your card resulting in
disqualification six - six it's almost
the mark of the devil I mean that's how
bad this is so if you don't you don't
sign you don't win I mean it's fairly
simple it's like the most rudimentary
part of golf
you make you know like when I play
miniature golf you make the two on the
rabbit for under giraffe three on the
windmill and you sign and you hand in
your cart and that's official it's not
official until you sign it so I feel bad
for Polly but rules are rules but there
is he joins a group of people who have
screwed this up visiting yeah I mean
famously in recent years Michelle Wie
when she was 18 so about a decade ago I
had a great round she was ready to kind
of break through and fulfill all her
potential and and walked out of the
scoring town without signing her car and
guess what she was done finished
didn't get to play the next round as a
guy Nick Gillespie Australia
professional played a great round didn't
sign his card disqualified
those are just some recent examples so
rich pulling luck
Polly would like to respond Paulie is
there something you'd like to say in
your defense damn first of all like to
thank everyone with Odyssey golf and
Callaway for getting me here today it
was more than than me to get me this
victory I have a couple questions rich
do the the USGA and the mini-golf
Association of America follow the exact
same scoring rules and scorebook famous
for it I told the same scoring rules my
father owned a miniature golf course and
you have to sign it look
certain things in life you you sign your
taxes right you know sign your passport
if you order you know a meatball sub and
you pay for it with a credit card they
don't give you the meatball sub until
you sign yes Paul Rach I had a couple
more questions for you do know this well
do all three competitors have the sky
sign the scorecard in the presence of
each other yeah okay those two didn't
sign in my presence are they also DQ'd
mmm but I don't know I don't know if
it's true though I'll tell you from my
side we finished around
McLovin scored it we started with
McLovin left first and then for it
tonight left and no one had signed the
scorecard in my presence or offered me
the opportunity to sign a scorecard rich
McLovin yes this is not true do you want
to know is happening Fritzi and I gather
to sign the scorecard Paulie is trying
to do a tiger Woods fist pump but is
making the cameraman do several takes of
the Tiger Woods fist pump so he keep tag
quote get it just right and blows is off
we said
we need to decide hey he's up it away
like no I need a better angle the Sun is
right here
McLovin actually lied four times and two
sentences there the camera asked me to
do the putt thing and they didn't then
neither of them asked me to sign the
scorecard that rule rule 11-4 if you ask
the cameraman to reshoot your Tiger
Woods fist-bump penalty okay all right
yes Pali pretty you're pretty truthful
guy did you in the club and asked me to
sign a scorecard
I don't recall is that a yes or no we
did not ask you to sign it we assumed
that that's some pretty new from there
did you sign it before we left the
property I did we both died and I saw
him sign at his door no why do they have
to ask somebody to sign a scorecard rich
shouldn't have to ask normally it's your
skin displayer as the player as the
competitor it's your responsibility to
attest that's what the word is to attest
that what you put down on that card is
factual but you have to do it on your
name sort of think it's a game of
integrity but you have to do it together
though rich right everybody has to be
together when you're signing it you
should you know have a witness
typically you you you attend you sign
your card and then somebody attests that
it is correct okay but so make love
inside and fritzy prissy attested that
and then the other way around
Fritzie sign and McLovin it was there as
a witness good enough and and so where
was Pauling in all this he was doing
Pfister's dude and winners take care of
the crowd you saw me throw the ball out
to the crowd there in eight rings as I
call rich thank you hey Paulie it's a
game of integrity not vanity thank you
thank you riff thank you that's a rich
rich Lerner from the golf channel
helping us out I think we got our answer
here for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
you
[Music]